il arrive parfois quand se regardant
dans un miroir on s'en dit qu'après tout
ce qu'on a fait c'est pas mal c'est le
cas de couples en une petite commune du
sud de la saône-et-loire voilà dix ans
elle a connu le déclin du tissage mais
chacun ya mis du sien pour faire
redémarrer les entreprises une volonté
qui a attiré la confiance de majorettes
dans la main d'oeuvre locale
aujourd'hui coublanc fête son dixième
anniversaire de la collaboration avec le
géant du jouet miniature un couple au la
tradition a du bon
au début du siècle chaque maison a son
atelier et son étiez à tisser il y a dix
ans crise du textile les métiers vont à
la casse aujourd'hui n'en reste qu'un le
travail à domicile lui est resté
l'assemblage des voitures majorette un
heureux concours de circonstances au
départ de quatre salariés on passe à 25
menée par le maire l'association de
bénévoles qui avaient relancé l'atelier
cède la place à une société privée
cmd en plus aujourd'hui 140 personnes
dont 115 à domicile activités souple
salaire d'appoint pour les femmes
désirant rester chez elle la formule
satisfait aussi le commanditaire
la rentabilité est un peu meilleur à
domicile bien que nous payons les gens
exactement sur les mêmes bases que ce
qu'il gagnerait en usine est un peu
meilleure en ce sens qu'on a besoin de
moins de bâtiments de moine contremaître
chef d'equipe pour les surveiller moins
de chauffage - taxe professionnelle sous
cet angle à cet intéressant et le temps
fera tout pour ne pas partir
nous essayons d'être fidèle et ça nous
promettons un final la seule chose qui
pourrait nous conduire à avoir moins de
travail en l1 ces civils
saint amand bref pour maintenir la vie à
coup blanc une entreprise ne suffisait
pas dans l'atelier textile dépose son
bilan aux 80 l'association repart en
campagne quand on charge les salaires
créer une scop pour relancer l'activité
depuis une société privée a pris le
relais vingt-cinq personnes employées
des métiers à la pointe de la
technologie
l'été prochain une fabrique de
compresseurs doit s'installer
toujours le même principe une entreprise
ferme la commune rachète les murs et le
terrain à terme une quinzaine d'emplois
en juin l'entreprise au service des
hommes la concertation le credo du maire
pour sauver l'emploi on débat on n'avait
rien et c'est quand on a vu qu'il
fallait justement une propriétaire des
murs et des sols pour maîtriser l'outil
de travail
on a décidé de construire saisine relais
d'acheter les locaux auront ya encore
deux qu'on a vu au cours de notre
tournée parce que j'estime que on est
quand même un peu les maîtres de la
situation et en cas de faillite ou de
bill dépôt de bilan
on peut exiger la reprise locaux pour
les donner à d'autres industriels ce qui
se passait alors à l'uimm tissage
symbole de renouveau trois lotissements
construits une nouvelle classe ou
n'augure et à l'école 52 enfants
scolarisés en 72 112 aujourd'hui les
naissances s'annonce bien
on peut vivre et travailler au pays la
vie ça roule à coup blanc